our correspondent Rob Harris can bring
us up to speed Rob this announcement
just now from British cycling who have
apologized for the upset to cause to
cyclists over the last year or so as
they've been reviewing their policy for
the participation of transgender women
in events and we have now the new policy
that has been announced and there will
be the introduction of a new open
category replacing the mail one and what
that will entail is it will feature that
category for transgender men transgender
women and individuals who identify as
non-binary there will be the separate
female category still but for those
assigned female at Birth and for
transgender men who've yet to undergo
hormone therapy well it's obviously a
hugely controversial thing in the world
of cycling and also this policy could be
seen by some as discriminatory and I've
been speaking to the British cycling CEO
John Dutton
it's actually some time to get to this
point and we do acknowledge that in the
suspension of the policy
um we have created some uncertainty
today is about showing Clarity
leadership in clear direction we have
taken consultation we have listened to
Riders from across the cycling Community
we have looked at the available medical
research and we've also taken a view
from a legal perspective and considering
all of those
um different facets uh that's the way
today that we've got to this policy that
we've announced with implementation to
follow the science isn't certain so why
go against inclusivity we've looked at a
range of different masses in getting to
this point first of all is to consult
with our athletes secondly is to look at
the scientific research that is
available at this point in time and
thirdly is from a legal perspective you
know we want to move forward we want to
give Clarity we want to give direction
we want to remove the uncertainty and
certainly the athletes have been
affected by this uncertainty created
over the past few months
um I'm really sorry for the anxiety for
the upset and for uh that have they have
been affected by getting to this point
today
transgender women and non-binary people
will still be able to compete in
non-competitive events in British
cycling such as the breeze competition
that they run but this impacts the
competitive events that are run here it
impacts things like qualification for
the world championships and the Olympics
and particularly the rider Emily Bridges
the transgender Rider who's 22 years old
she had set the National Junior men's
record over 25 miles in 2018 she came
out as a transgender woman in 2020 and
then began hormone therapy last year to
reduce her testosterone levels she was
hoping to compete in her first women's
event 40 months ago but she was barred
from doing so because she was still
registered with the world body as a male
and as I understand the British cycling
Chiefs have yet to be able to make
contact with her to discuss this new
policy they are trying to consult as
widely as possible and to inform and it
is set to take effect later this year
year but it comes as the international
governing body the UCI is yet to form
its own policy after deciding it would
reopen its review in recent weeks on the
participation of transgender women in
female events after considerable
attention on a victory for one
transgender woman in a female event in
the United States in recent weeks but
this British cycling position reflects
those we've seen in other sports like
Triathlon and indeed in athletics
Athletics very recently deciding that
those are signed male at Birth could not
compete in female event we do a wait to
hear actually some of the reaction from
across the world of cycling as cyclists
are just receiving this news in the UK